les antennes relais de téléphone mobile
sont elles dangereuses pour la santé
certains le craignent
il n'y a pas de preuve pour le moment
mais à saint cyr l'école dans les
yvelines c'est l'inquiétude
une antenne a été installée sur une
école et l'adaf elle même vient de
reconnaître huit cas suspects de cancer
chez des enfants du quartier
sylvain le kent et jean-bernard hier
depuis plusieurs années les parents
d'élèves de cette école soupçonne ces
antennes relais installées sur le toit
de l'établissement d'être à l'origine de
trois cas de cancers déclarés chez des
enfants qui ont été scolarisés ici deux
sont décédés d'une pathologie
extrêmement rares le cancer dutronc
saisi la das a fini par reconnaître huit
cas suspects de cancer d'enfants sur
toute la commune sans pour autant faire
de lien avec les antennes relais pour
les parents d'élèves
c'est un premier pas nous on veut
d'abord savoir s'il ya un rapport et 6e
trouve qu'un appât défaut nous montrer
les résultats de l' enquête de la dass
et de liên vs montre qu'il ya
effectivement des suspicions au moins au
niveau des cancers de l'enfant
le lien n'est toujours pas fait et
et on évite même soigneusement de faire
le lien entre la reconnaissance de cet
excès sur les cancers de l'enfant et les
champs électromagnétiques
la dass en revanche ne reconnaît pas de
cas suspect de cancer chez les adultes
de la commune mais pour le maire l'étude
de la dass n'a pas été suffisamment
approfondie à ce jour donc la dass
interrogé l'ensemble des médecins de la
ville et des médecins activement sur les
villes jouxtant donc la ville de saint
cyr l'école mais ceci dit il y a
également des personnes qui habitent
sacyr ils vont travailler à paris et qui
vont faire soigner à paris
et ceci ne vont pas apparaître donc je
pense que l'étude est à reprendre
et c'est pour ça que je demande à la
dass d'étudier l'ensemble de la
population du quartier par un
questionnaire tout simple la dass et les
opérateurs sfr et orange n'ont pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions
de leur côté la mairie et les
associations attendent toujours qu'une
étude d'impact autour des antennes
relais soit enfin diligentée afin d'y
voir un peu plus clair